Speaker 1: It's not been a particularly
good couple of weeks for radical
Trumpist Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. She, of course, had these
incredible hearings about her involvement in
allegedly inciting the Trump riot insurrection
during which she very obviously perjured
herself multiple times lying under oath.
She then was exposed further by some leaked text
messages, text messages involving Donald Trump's
former chief of staff, Mark Meadows, in which she
seems to very clearly be telling him, you know,
people are talking about and maybe we should
look into this whole martial law thing now.
Hilariously, she misspelled martial law, MERS, a
ll like the name rather than a major trial. That's
sort of like a sidebar comedy element to the
entire thing. But she was finally confronted about
these text messages by CNN reporter Jim Acosta.
He did the ambush thing, as I call it, where he
just kind of found her on the street, as far as
we know now. I want to be open to the possibility
that this was scheduled and this was just the
way it developed where it was. Yeah, you can
talk to me as I walk between meetings. As far as
I know, this was sort of like the ambush style.
And I'm going to talk about that in a little
bit because I have some thoughts about that
approach. But the subject matter here is
fascinating, and you might notice that
Jim Acosta does a really nice touch here where he
mentions the misspelling of Marshall a bunch of
times during this confrontation. So pay attention
to that. Notice how Marjorie Taylor GREENE will
not stop speaking. Her approach is to try to
not let Acosta even get a word in. Check it out.
Speaker 4: The passing recall.
Speaker 3: What's going on there?
You know, Jim, you have a show and in all
fairness, you try to present this image of me
to your viewers, and it's just really not correct.
Speaker 4: Well, we're just trying to get some
answers. Did you send a text asking for
the president to declare martial law?
Speaker 3: You know, I don't recall
those being my text messages,
but have you read the text message that is
that you're referring to? I did. It actually
says if you it was misspelled, but it's flashing.
Speaker 1: So first mention of the misspelling.
Speaker 3: Yes. If you read it correctly, Jim,
your problem is, is you're lying again right now.
It says, I do not know on those
things. That's what that text message.
Speaker 1: One of the funniest things that
has to be mentioned is on the one hand,
she won't actually own up to it being her
text. Now, of course it is. It's her text.
There's no dispute about the technical aspect
of it. But she keeps saying the text is being
misrepresented. It's like, well, if you
didn't send it, if you're sticking by,
I don't even recall that it's my text. Does it
really matter what it said if it's not even really
your text? She wants to play both sides on it.
Speaker 3: Why even bring it out and bring up
Marshall? You know, your problem is you're just
another one of those liars on television, and
people hate it. I can't stand the liars. I'm tired
of someone saying I don't know how to call it.
I suppose a text message require quote it. What
does it say? I don't know what those things. Hang
on. What's great about Dancing on Ice, for one.
Speaker 1: And the entire time he's looking
for it, she's just badgering.
Speaker 3: His friend out loud.
Let's take a look. I mean, my question laid
it out. What does it actually say? Okay,
what is the text message? Read the whole
thing. Let's look at. Okay, let's read it.
Speaker 4: But you're saying you don't recall it.
Speaker 3: I don't know if that's my text message
or not, but if you want to talk about a text.
Speaker 1: I don't even know if I said it,
but you damn well better quote me correctly from
it so that you actually tell people what I meant
in the text message. I don't
even know if I send the message.
Speaker 3: Read the text message, do some
signaling. Let's take a look. Okay. Read the exact
text message that talking about. Agree to read
it. Let's take a look here how we got an article.
Why don't you find the actual text message?
Speaker 4: Let's see here. Let's hang on a second.
In our private chat with only members, several
are saying the only way to save our republic is
for Trump to call for martial law.
Speaker 3: Martial was keep
going. I don't I don't.
Speaker 4: Know on those.
Speaker 3: Things. I just wanted you to tell
him. I don't know. Is that what that says?
It says I don't know. I'm just saying. But wait,
how do you up this text message that's supposedly
mine? I don't know. That is what is right.
Speaker 1: Jim, you're misquoting me from a text
message that is supposedly mine, but I don't know.
Speaker 3: It says some members of the why? Well,
I don't know why. I don't know if that's my
take. It says I don't know on those things.
Why don't you tell that story? Are you saying you
don't know you're lying? You're a liar about why
people do not like. Why are you the liar? Why do
you lie on television from are your viewers. I'm
not trying to lie. I don't know. You're trying
to ask you. You're teasing me as something.
And then why are you read the actual
words? It tells another story.
Speaker 1: So the constant talking to try to
prevent him from actually getting a word and.
That's a technique that's often used. It's the
same technique she used in the debate last night
at the top of the show. We covered some of the
Georgia elections that are going on. One of them
is Marjorie Taylor GREENE, Republican primary.
She had her make cut yesterday at a debate or
the day before. I found the clip yesterday. Maybe
it was from the day before she had her might cut
because she wouldn't stop talking. Okay. So this
is a strategy that she employs. It's a technique,
a tactic, I guess we would say. She also
simultaneously doesn't recall whether
it's actually her text message, but is mad that
what she meant to say is being misinterpreted.
How do you know what you meant to say if
it's not even clear you sent the message?
If I say I don't know whether I wrote it, how
can I know what the intention of the writer is?
If it's me, I would know. But I'm saying I don't
actually remember. It's full on double speak. Now,
let me talk a little bit about ambush style.
Let's assume that this was ambush style,
meaning Jim Acosta just kind of found her, was
waiting for her, showed up with a camera. It's not
a tactic I use. And the reason I don't do it is
it doesn't strike me as fair as a general thing.
We have an interview process and sometimes people
declined to be interviewed. And I don't like that,
but I respect it in the sense that I can't compel
the same way that I can't compel Harvard to allow
me to speak there. These conservatives often say
I'm being silenced because a school won't have
me for an event. Well, though, they don't have
to. People don't have to speak to me. So for me,
if I request an interview, request to interview,
people don't want to do it for me to then show up
and kind of ambush them. To me, it doesn't
feel like the right thing to do. However,
however, I am sensitive to an explanation that
sometimes is given for using the technique for
people in positions of power, which
is they are in a position of power.
They have legislative authority in this case.
They can be involved in making law all these.
They're supposed to be accountable to the people
and they won't answer real basic questions about,
are you lying or are you telling lies? What's
going on here? When you say you don't recall,
but then here's the text is it yours? And they
won't sit down and actually be questioned.
You can make the case that reporters are left
with no choice. So there are circumstances where
if it's truly a reporter and someone in a position
of power, I get having no other option. It's not
a technique I use, but I can see both sides of
the discussion. Let me know what you think about
the technique. Send me your thoughts and maybe
we'll do a follow up on the ambush technique.